[Music]
epigenetics is the study of changes in
gene function that are heritable
and that are not attributed to
alterations of the dna sequence
epigenetics can cause changes in gene
expression but that are not changes in
the dna sequence
these mechanisms include dna methylation
histone modification
and non-coding rna such as micro rnas
and the effect of non-coding repeating
regions in the dna code
before we go into the specifics of
epigenetic variation
or regulation let's discuss the
structure of dna
and how it is organized in eukaryotic
cells
as you remember the foundational
understanding about phenotypes
is that dna codes for genes those genes
are transcribed into mrna which are then
translated into proteins
however these processes appear to be
regulated by a variety of mechanisms
that are not directly recorded in the
actual
code of dna in fact individuals and
members of different species can have
similar dna like twins or many conserved
genes like humans and monkeys
but significant phenotypic variation can
be easily observed that is the result of
epigenetic changes that are either
established and passed through
generations
or acquired and lost throughout the
organism's lifetime
the eukaryotic cell has a nucleus that
contains tightly packaged dna folded
into structures that we all know as
chromosomes
these are packaged together by the way
of chromatin protein complexes that the
dna is wrapped around
on these images you can see how the dna
string has more bumps
or beads these visible beads are called
histones
when these beads were originally
discovered scientists first confused
them with genes until eventually it was
proven that the string-like structures
actually contained the genetic code
histones can be either grouped together
forming lumps of dna
or as we can see in the picture on the
right relaxed and spread out
the changes in the way dna is packaged
is used for cell division when whole
chromosomes need to be moved around or
to regulate what code is more or less
accessible for transcription
the regulation of dna compactness is
regulated in several ways
one of these is dna methylation
cytosine is one of the nucleotide that
can be modified by a methyl group
ch3 catalyzed by a specialized enzyme
called dna methyl transferase
in the first minutes of life when we are
composed of a single cell
and this epigenetic information has been
wiped clean in the fertilized egg
the methyl groups have been removed and
every gene is like all the others
through the process of cell
differentiation dna methyl transferases
add methyl groups to genes shutting off
some
in activating others when a cell divides
the epigenetic information must be
transmitted to each of the new cells by
a different dna methyl transferase
called dnmt1 dnmt1 adds the proper
methyl groups to these dna strands as it
is replicated
the information is propagated in a
tricky way
the methyl groups almost always added to
cytosine bases with these sequences
cg and gc notice that both strands have
a cytosine so
in a methylated region of dna both
strands will have a methyl group when
the dna is replicated
each of the new dna double helices will
have one old strand
complete with methyl groups and one new
strand which is not methylated
so dnmt1 just needs to look for the cg
bases sites
where only one strand has a methyl group
the basic repeating unit of chromatin is
the nucleosome
in which 146 base pairs of dna wraps
around an octamer of core histones
consisting of pairs of h3
h4 h2a and h2b
the terminal tails of histones protrude
out of the nucleosome
and are subject to a variety of
post-translational modifications
such as acetylation phosphorylation
ubiquitination and lysine and arginine
methylation
acetylation was the first of these
modifications to be linked with active
transcription
subsequently phosphorylation of histone
h3 was found to cooperate with a
situation in translational activation
some histone methylation events have
also been associated with transcription
activation
and others with gene silencing one
important aspect of histones
is that they can be changed to alter how
much packing the dna is capable of
there are several modifications that
affect how well dna is packaged
the basic regulation is done via groups
of atoms that are at the ends of
histones
these can be of several types and will
have a positive or a negative charge
that either attract them together or
force them apart
the dna region that is wrapped around
the histones can be more or less
accessible causing variation in gene
expression
histone proteins or nucleosomes undergo
a host of different post-translational
modifications including phosphorylation
acetylation and methylation which have
profound effects on the remodeling of
chromatin
histone modifications can function
either individually or combinatorially
to govern such processes as
transcription
replication dna repair and apoptosis
the methyl groups of atoms increased
packing
acetyl group decreases packing
phosphoryl group can be attached to the
histones
and cause a decrease in packing these
groups of atoms are attached to various
types of histones at various locations
as the dna is wrapped around the
histones and can be more or less
accessible
various positions of the dna are
affected
these include the promoter region
transcription start sites
and the introns and exons of genes
each one of these elements can have a
significant effect on the level of gene
expression
on alternative splicing as well as other
downstream regulation of pathways
you